Ich bin Rufin Müller.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Erwin Müller.
Wie heißen Sie Herr Müller?
Herr Müller oder Frau Müller?
Herr. Erwin ist ein männlicher Name.
Ich bin 65 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Wann bin ich geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 19.08.1959.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1 Meter 73 groß.
Wie viel wiegen Sie es für Zeit?
Ich bin ungefähr 80 kg schwer.
Danke für die Informationen Herr Müller.
Was würdest du uns beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Ich habe immer wieder in den letzten Tagen
Schmerzen, vor allem im Oberbaubau-Bereich.
An den Rippen auf der rechten Seite.
Könnten Sie bitte genau zeigen, wo die Schmerzen starten?
Die rechten Seite?
Ja, rechte Seite.
Seit wann haben Sie genau diese Schmerzen?
Ich glaube, die sind das erste Mal vor ungefähr 10 Tagen aufgetreten.
Okay, war der Beginn plötzlich oder eher allmählich?
Also das war, beim ersten Mal war es plötzlich da.
Okay.
Wie würden Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben, sind Sie eher dumm, stechend, brennend?
Die sind jetzt unterschiedlich.
Am Anfang vor 10 Tagen war das so ein kampfartiger Schmerz.
Jetzt ist das mehr so stechend brennender Schmerz.
Okay, strahlende Schmerzen, irgendein Wochen aus zum Beispiel, Brustberei.
Ich habe manchmal den Eindruck, wenn der Schmerz kommt, tut es mir im Rücken auch weh.
Okay.
Wie haben sich die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit, haben die Schmerzen zugenommen?
Also wie gesagt, der Schmerz hat sich gewandelt, habe ich den Eindruck.
Ganz am Anfang waren das sehr, sehr starke Schmerzen,
dass ich kaum aushalten konnte.
Jetzt sind das Schmerzen, die immer wieder mal kommen, aber das sind mehr so brennende, stechende Schmerzen.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder liebt, zum Beispiel Nahrungsaufnahme
oder Rücken auf der Rücken liegen?
Nein, ich habe den Eindruck, das hat irgendwas mit der Ernährung zu tun.
Ganz am Anfang, immer wenn ich gegessen habe, waren die Schmerzen am stärksten.
Jetzt ist es so ein bisschen unabhängig davon.
Hab ich richtig verstanden, dass am Anfang die Schmerzen nach dem Essen zugenommen haben hatten?
Ja, richtig.
Aber jetzt ist es unabhängig von dem Essen.
Ja, richtig. Jetzt ist das so ein bisschen unabhängig davon.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Auch in der Schmerz sind die Schmerzen sehr leichter, sehr unerträglich.
Wie würde sie einordnen?
Momentan würde ich sagen, dass es so vier bis fünf, aber vor zehn Tagen war das schon so acht, neun, dass ich fast schreien musste.
Waren Sie deswegen beim anderen Arsch?
Nein, das war es mal zwei, drei Mal.
Das hat auch nur ganz kurz angehalten, so zehn Minuten, fünfzehn Minuten.
Dann waren Sie weg.
Ich habe gedacht, das ist vorbei, aber jetzt sind die Schmerzen eben anders da.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt gekommen.
Sie haben gut gemacht, indem Sie zu uns gekommen sind.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas unternommen, zum Beispiel eine Medikament, haben Sie eine Medikament eingenommen?
Also ich hatte zu Hause so Kopfschmerz, Tablet, nicht glaube ich, Paracetamol oder wie das heißt.
Davon habe ich mal zwei, drei Stücke eingenommen.
Hat das Paracetamol Ihnen geholfen?
Nicht so richtig, nee.
Okay, in der Vergangenheit haben Sie solche Beschwerden schon einmal gehabt, oder ist das erst mal?
Nee, in der Vergangenheit habe ich sowas nicht gehabt, kann mich nicht dran erinnern.
Erste Mal, okay.
Hat dies einen Unfall?
Nee, Unfall hatte ich nicht.
Neben diese Schmerzen, Herr Müller, haben Sie andere Beschwerden, die Übelheit, erbrechen?
Erbrochen habe ich nicht, aber jetzt, wenn die Schmerzen so kommen, habe ich den Eindruck, es ist mir so ein bisschen übel.
Aber erbrechen muss ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Nee, Kopfschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich müde oder abgeschlagen?
Also, ich habe den Eindruck, mir geht es nicht gut.
Also, ich bin nicht so leistungsfähig wie vor zehn, fünfzehn Tagen.
Ich bin so ein bisschen schlapp und ich habe den Eindruck, ich habe, also, als wenn ich sehr schwer geahnt habe,
sehr schwer gearbeitet hätte und müde bin.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Haben Sie bemerken?
Nee, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Atemprobleme?
Nee, Atemprobleme habe ich auch nicht.
Nein.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre allgemeinen Zustand eine Frage stellen.
Haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Was ist denn Fieber?
Fieber erhöhte Körpertemperatur.
Ja, ich fühle mich zwar warm an, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das Fieber ist.
Haben Sie das nicht gemessen, oder?
Nee, ich habe keinen Thermometer zu Hause.
Okay. Haben Sie Schutteilfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Nachtschweiß? Was meinen Sie damit?
Oder schwitzen Sie mehr als sonst in der Nacht,
oder müssen Sie Ihre Unterwäsche anziehen, anziehen oder umziehen?
Wechseln, okay.
Also, ja, ich habe den Eindruck, ich muss ein bisschen,
ich schwitze ein bisschen mehr, aber Wäsche muss ich nicht wechseln.
Okay.
Aber Sie fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhldank?
Nee, mir ist nur aufgefallen.
Vor zehn Tagen war der Stuhl mal ziemlich hell gewesen.
Jetzt ist das wieder normal.
Das ist normal.
Haben Sie zum Beispiel Blutbeimängungen im Blutbemmer?
Im Stuhl?
Nee, Blutbeimängungen im Stuhl habe ich nicht gesehen.
Okay, das ist gut.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Müller?
Momentan nicht so gut.
Seit zehn Tagen?
Ja, ungefähr.
Vor zehn Tagen waren diese starken Schmerzen da.
Die sind weg, aber seit drei, vier Tagen fühle ich mich nicht so gut.
Und diese brennend stechenen Schmerzen im Oberbau, die sind da.
Und die wollen einfach nicht weg.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit Abruf oder Suche genommen?
Ungerwollte.
Nein, nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob ich in den zehn Tagen abgenommen habe.
Aber vorher hatte ich keinen Gewichtsverlust.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Mit Schlafen habe ich keine Probleme.
Okay, haben Sie Rotbrennen, Herr Müller?
Rotbrennen oder Saueraufstoßen?
Saueraufstoßen? Nein, nicht, dass ich rüste.
Okay, Herr Müller, ich möchte einige Fragen zu Ihrer kranken Geschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie unter chronische Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankheit,
erhöhte Blutwertwerte, Bluthochdruck?
Ja, ich glaube, mein Hausarzt hat irgendwann mal gesagt,
meine Cholesterinwerte seien so ein bisschen hoch.
Aber Medikamenten nehme ich momentan nicht ein.
Keine Medikamente.
Warum wurde das festgestellt?
Oh, das weiß ich nicht, aber das dürfte mindestens fünf Jahre her sein.
Gehen Sie regelmäßig Ihren Hausarzt, um Ihre Cholesterinwerte zu überprüfen?
Nein, nein, nein, habe ich nicht gemacht.
Ich fühle mich eigentlich gut, ich habe keine Probleme.
Deswegen bin ich auch nicht mehr hingegangen.
Okay, haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen
oder Cholesterinwerte?
Nein, nicht, dass ich rüste.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Nein, keine Medikamente.
Oh, das ist auch gut.
Herr Müller, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein, ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern.
Sind Sie schon einmal im Krankenhaus behandelt?
Ob ich behandelt worden bin?
Nein, ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern, im Krankenhaus gewesen zu sein.
Gut, das ist auch gut.
Okay, sind bei Ihnen Allergien bekannt oder Unfältigkeiten?
Ja, bestimmte Nahrungsmittel, ja, aber sonst wüsste ich nicht.
Was für Nahrungsmittel reagieren Sie allergisch?
Ich reagiere auf Citrusfrüchte, so ein bisschen allergisch.
Wie allergieren Sie gegen diese Citrusfrüchte?
Haben Sie Bileum?
Nein, wenn ich davon etwas esse, bekomme ich dann Yukreis am gesamten Körper
und dann bilden sich so Bläschen auf der Haut.
Okay.
Haben Sie sonst keine Allergien oder Unfältigkeiten?
Nein, nicht, dass mir bekannt wäre.
Wie ist Ihre Impfstatus?
Sind Sie gegen Corona geimpft?
Ja, so wie alle, 3-4 Mal habe ich mich empfunden lassen.
Gegen auch Kinderkrankheiten?
Bestimmt, ich weiß es jetzt nicht, aber meine Eltern sagten, sie hätten alles gemacht.
Okay, das ist auch gut.
Waren Sie in nächster Zeit im Ausland?
Ja, mit der Familie waren wir mal vor einem halben Jahr in Irland gewesen.
Okay, jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Geohnheiten einige wissen.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Müller?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Haben Sie noch nie geraucht?
Nein, ich habe nie geraucht.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Nein, ganz selten, vielleicht einmal, zweimal im Jahr.
Was trinken Sie gerne?
Manchmal Wein, ja, zu irgendwelchen besonderen Anlässen, aber sonst nicht.
Okay, routinmäßig muss ich fragen, ob Sie Kontakt mit Drogen haben.
Drogen? Nein, mit Drogen habe ich nichts an Gott.
Ja, Herr Müller, ich möchte über Ihre Familiengeschichte wissen.
Ich meine über Blutverwandtschafte.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, meine Eltern leben nicht mehr.
Es wird mir leid zu hören.
Woran sind Sie verstorben, wenn ich fragen darf?
Mein Vater hatte einen Schlaganfall gehabt vor fünf Jahren.
Er ist daran gestorben und meine Mutter vor zwei Jahren, ich glaube, sie hat Brustkrebs gehabt.
Brustkrebs? Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch eine Schwester, ja.
Sind die Geschwister gesund?
Die ist gesund, ja.
Okay, Herr Müller, was machen Sie beruflich?
Also, ich bin kurz vor der Pension.
Das heißt, ich werde in zwei Monaten brenntet werden.
Ich bin vom Beruf her Bauingenieur.
Okay, sind Sie im Alltagsstress ausgesetzt?
Nicht mehr als sonst.
Nehmen Sie allein?
Nein, mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, einen Sohn.
Okay.
Ist er gesund?
Der ist auch gesund, ja.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Müller, ich habe keine Fragen mehr.
Haben wir alles besprochen?
Oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, mir fällt nichts an.
Nur diese Schmerzen machen wir zu schaffen.
Ich werde Sie jetzt noch körperlich untersuchen.
Dann nehmen wir Blutab, machen einen Ultraschall.
Dann besprechen wir, was das Problem sein könnte.
Oder die Befunde.
Dann sehen wir, wie es weitergeht.
Ich möchte Sie, dass Sie stationär bleiben möchten oder ob eine ambulante Therapie möglich ist.
Okay, ein Verstärk.
Lasst uns die Unterhörzungen ergeblich abwarten.
Bitte nehmen Sie Plastik und Wartezima.
Ich gehe zu Ihnen.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Herr Müller, haben Sie Farbveränderungen bei Ihnen an Ihrer Haut?
Oder Ihre Augen?
Oh, nein, weiß ich nicht.
Ich hatte vor einigen Tagen den Eindruck,
dass meine Augen ein bisschen gelb sind.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Danke schön.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich habe noch eine andere Frage.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie vor zehn Tagen Bauchschmerzen gehabt haben.
Also sind die Schmerzen bauehaft?
Oder manchmal von selbst gegangen und wieder angekommen?
Also vor zehn Tagen kamen Sie, wie gesagt, spontan
und waren dann nach einigen Minuten wieder weg.
Okay.
Und jetzt sind das andere Schmerzen, jetzt sind die schon länger.
Manchmal spüre ich die auch so ein bisschen dauerhaft.
Okay.
Also, so weit nach der Genalioszmann.
Andere Kollegen.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Herr Müller, waren Sie schon mal vor Sorge,
unter suchung, eine Koloskopie oder eine Darmspiegelung gehabt?
Nein, ich habe das leider noch nicht machen lassen.
Okay, die zweite Frage ist, Sie haben gesagt,
Sie haben gesagt, Sie waren ja schon vor Sorge,
und wir waren dann in Urin, in der Dunkelbesein.
Urin war ein bisschen dunkel gewesen, ja?
Okay.
Ich habe eine andere Frage.
Herr Müller, wenn Sie ein Kollege haben,
Sie sagen, Sie haben jetzt erst als Kind einen Eklat,
und Sie sagen, Sie sind ein Geschenk,
ist das ein Geschenk oder eine Ersatzgeschichte.
Sie haben eine Ersatzgeschichte, auch eine Ersatzgeschichte,
auch eine Erspangeung.
Wir können, wenn ihr so eine Zeit ...
Dankeschön.
wenn ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte, haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Gerne, klar.
Es handelt sich um Herrn Erwin Müller. Er ist 65 Jahre alt, 1,73 m groß, 80 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns seit 10 Tagen bestehende Oberbauschmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen sind vor 10 Tagen plötzlich auftreten.
Der Patient beschreibt die Schmerzen am Anfang krampfartig, jetzt als stechen und brennend.
Die Schmerzen sind am Anfang 8 bis 10 bewertet, jetzt mit 4 bis 5 von 10 bewertet.
Er hatte keine Unfall gehabt. Er hatte begleitet und über Übelkeit ohne Erbrechen.
Er hat vor 10 Tagen begleitet und über Übelkeit ohne Erbrechen.
Er hatte ein 65-jähriger männlicher Patient, der seit 10 Tagen rezidivierende Oberbauchschmerzen beklagt.
Am Anfang waren die Schmerzen mehr krampfartig, jetzt brennend Schmerzen begleitet von bisschen Übelkeit ohne Erbrechen.
Am Anfang war die Schmerzinternität so hoch, dass man auf der Skala von 1 bis 10 bei 8 nennen würde.
Aktuell gibt er 4 bis 5 auf der Skala. Er fühlt sich so ein bisschen vibrikan, Temperatur hat aber nicht gemessen.
Vor 10 Tagen hat er einen hellen oder aufgehellten Stuhl und einen dunklen Urin bemerkt.
Bei einem Patienten ist eine sitgesprückte Allergin bekannt, die sich mit Prüritus und Leschen bemerkt.
Er ist kurspensioniert, davor hat er als Bauingenieur gearbeitet.
Er wird in 2 Monaten pensioniert werden.
Er ist verheiratet, hat einen gesunden Sohn, lebt mit seiner Frau.
Man muss zusammen sagen, man kann nicht zusammen weglassen.
Er ist in der Familie Anemnese zu erwähnen, dass sein Vater vor 5 Jahren in einem Apoplex verstorben ist.
Er ist in einem Apoplex verstorben.
Die Anemnese, die aufgrund der Symptomatik, denke ich an eine Gastritis.
Als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen Urkust, Windrückli, Reflexkrankheit, eine Gallenwenkprobleme in Betracht.
Er hat einige Hinweise gegeben, wobei das Ganze wahrscheinlich führen wird.
Er hat sich im Spiegel angeschaut und kam in die Augen gelb vor.
Er ist nicht gelb, sondern er ist nicht gelb.
Er ist gelb, dann ist er wieder weg.
Er ist in Gallengangs Steinabgang.
Wie erklären wir uns die aktuellen Beschwerden?
Er ist in Gallenwägen.
Was ist der nächste Schritt?
Was machen Sie?
Er ist in Gallenwägen.
Ich stelle die folgenden Fragen oft.
Was ist Murphseerzeichen?
Was können Sie antworten?
Da muss man natürlich schon immer wissen,
wie man das mit den chirurgischen Untersuchungsmethoden
immer gucken muss.
Wir machen das immer wieder.
Was wollen Sie damit sehen,
ob das mit der Gallenblase zu tun hat?
Wo macht man diese Untersuchung?
Wenn Sie sowas nennen, müssen Sie es dann auch demonstrieren können.
Wo müssen Sie diese Untersuchung machen?
Wo drücken Sie?
Was wollen Sie erwarten?
Ein Loslossschmerz?
Wenn Sie sowas nennen, müssen Sie es beherrschen.
Ich sage zu Leuten, die in Prüfungen gehen,
sagen Sie nur das, was Sie kennen.
Dann machen Sie einen Fehler.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?